hey everyone if you're new to this
channel my name is lucy and i make
videos all about tech
career and student advice so if that
sounds like something you're interested
in
please consider subscribing to stay
updated so as you can probably tell from
the title of this video
i did fail my aws sysops administrator
associate exam
not once but twice and honestly it's
something that's a bit embarrassing for
me
considering i passed three aws exams
beforehand on the first try
but i think it's something that is quite
important for me to
share with all of you because there were
so many learnings that came out of it
so many things that i wish i could have
done differently and going forward i
think there will be a lot of mistakes
that i'll end up avoiding in the future
so i'm going to be breaking up this
video into three parts
i want to talk about the real reasons
why i failed twice my advice to people
who want to take an aws exam
and what resources i used for the sysops
administrator certification
if you're interested in seeing a
particular section of this video i've
included time stamps in the description
below
so feel free to skip around to what
you'll find the most useful
let's get into it okay so now i'm going
to talk about the real reasons i failed
the exam twice
i think the biggest reason is because i
really underestimated the difficulty of
the exam
a bit about my cloud learning journey i
started off in august
i did the certified cloud practitioner
certification that took about three
weeks
i then did the aws solutions architect
associate
which took another month and then the
month after i sat the aws
developer associate exam so before
sitting the aws sysops exam the exam
that i failed
i achieved three certification exams in
three months
and at that time i was feeling quite
confident and i thought that the
aws associate would just be the fourth
one that i passed
a month later so because of that i
wanted to
challenge myself a bit further and set
the exam a bit earlier
by sitting it two weeks after the
developer associate
and what i was studying for the exam
i really took it slow um i didn't really
study much the first week i wanted to
take a bit of a break
so that only left me one week to study
for the sisops administrative exam
which i think is definitely possible to
pass
in that in a short amount of time for
certain people
but for me i don't come from a very
technical background i don't really have
too much hands-on experience with aws
and i know that there's a lot of overlap
between the three
exams but even still i think it was
quite a bit of a stretch
to put the exam that close right after
the
developer associate exam so i guess the
main thing was
feeling a bit too overconfident and
thinking the exam was easier than it
actually was
especially after looking at some forums
online and seeing people talk about how
the sysops exam
has a lot of content that is already
covered in the previous three
certifications i thought that it would
be okay to skim through the video
lectures for the concepts that
i've already seen before but what i've
realized is that each exam
approaches the aws services in a
different set of lens
so for example the sysops administrator
exam it really looks at these
concepts through the lens of someone
who's a systops or devops
engineer working with aws another reason
i failed twice
is because i didn't really take the best
approach when studying for this exam
if you've seen my previous video on how
i passed through aws certifications in
three months
you'd have seen that i emphasized a lot
on doing hands-on lab exercises
and because i gave myself only one week
to study for the sysops administrator
exam
i didn't really do too many lab
exercises
i focused more on doing practice exams
and these practice exams
after a while i found myself just
memorizing these answers or
seeing a question and not already
knowing the answer because i've done
the same practice exam material over and
over again and this is not the best
approach because when you go into the
exam you get a completely different set
of questions and they'll have
way different answers because of the way
that the questions are phrased
so it's not the best approach to just
keep doing practice exams without really
knowing
deep down what's underneath these
services and
that was a big mistake that i made
because i think that not only
made me fail the exam but it also
stunted my learning as well
so i made sure that after fame twice the
third time
i went back to the video content and i
did all the lab exercises that they had
and i think that really helps because
for the sysops exam
more so than the other ones hands-on ex
hands-on experience is very necessary
because a big part of the exam is about
troubleshooting so the questions might
be something like
okay so you have this service this
service goes down
what could be the potential reasons and
if you don't have
so if you have the aws systems exam
coming up or
just for any other awc exam in general
please remember to do
hands-on exercises to make sure that
you're able to validate your knowledge
and it's better for memory retention as
well even after
you finish your exam it's easier for you
to
keep the knowledge fresh in your mind so
that in the future if you ever need it
for your role it's way easier for you to
pick the skills back
up so moving on to the second part of
this video i wanted to share some exam
tips
on how to pass aways exams in general
but also how to pass the sysops
administrator exam
on this board you can see there's a
cycle of learning
to start off with i recommend learning
the content that is relevant to the aws
exam that you're going to be taking
and when you feel ready applying what
you've learned to hands-on lab exercises
and then following that up with practice
exams it's okay at the start if you end
up getting 50
60 or even 40 in your practice exams i
think practice exams are a really good
way to tell
where your gaps are in your knowledge so
that you can go back to the learning
material
and that way you can make sure that you
not only pass the real exam but you
understand
everything that is required for you to
know in each aws certification
so in terms of advice more specifically
for the syslops exam
i would really recommend diving into the
concepts of monitoring and
troubleshooting in a lot of practice
exams i've seen that there's a very big
emphasis on the cloud watch
whether that be cloudwatch events
cloudless alarms car watch logs and it's
very important for you to know the
difference between these services
and when you should be applying it to
which scenario with the aws sysops
administrator exam
you need to know a lot more than what
these services are what they do
but also on how you can use these
services to
create fault tolerant highly available
applications something that i found very
useful
is reading faqs of each of the aws
services a lot of services like ec2
cloudwatch s3
rds they have their own sets of faqs and
by reading these documents you'll be
able to gain a more holistic
understanding of what you might get
tested on for the final part of this
video i wanted to talk about what
resources i used for the sysops
administrator exam
and what i would recommend doing so the
resources that
i've used is already linked in the
description below so i'm not going to
spend too long on this section because i
think it really depends on
the person what your preferred learning
style is whether you
like ebooks or like video courses it's
okay if you want to use half of one
course before realizing that you prefer
the teaching style of another course
try things out and see what you like and
what's best for you
and this wraps up my video of how i
failed an aws exam
twice i hope you got something out of
this video please give it a like if you
did
and subscribe for more tech student
advice and career related videos